look we got the Mexican OT in here that
Mexican OT
what's going on baby thank you so much
for having me it's a pleasure let's have
fun baby welcome sir yes sir thank you
so who's your favorite wrestler of all
time
um
man dude I'm gonna have to go to John
Cena Cena I would love to say uh Edgar
you know I mean Edgar Eddie Eddie
Guerrero you know all right but I feel
like it was like because how old are you
because Eddie died like yeah I'm 24 I
just turned uh 24 right now so you
probably didn't really get to watch
Eddie like for real for real when he was
like popping popping nah not so much but
like I said just because of what he
stands for how he came out the low rider
all that yeah man I'm saying he had
Texas Mexican that's really what it is
but you know what I'm saying and now
with the WWE Network you can catch up on
us right right bro the video game I
bought the newest one and like they had
like uh on the story mode you can unlock
characters in their skins you could
unlock the Rey Mysterio costume uh I
think it was like 90
it was 90 something it was Halloween and
he had the all purple suit Halloween
Havoc yeah that's crazy yeah that's
what's up you know you'll never be able
to unlock who Chris Benoit why because
he murdered his entire family in a
steroid rage damn and then killed
himself
it was a steroid Rage that's what that
was yeah holy [__] that makes that [__]
way crazy I thought he was just
depressed I'm sure it was a lot of that
he was on roids he had a ton of
concussions Jew stuff
oh that's crazy murdered his whole
family yeah no that's that's insane but
but also one of the greatest wrestlers
of all time yeah but somehow he raced
from the books
it's crazy you remember Sergeant
Slaughter of course yeah he was crazy I
feel like Sergeant Slaughter was like a
little racist yeah but I mean dog like
there's some of those old like wrestlers
I love Uncle Ruckus
do you like The Boondocks bro by far but
definitely top three for me wait I gotta
see I gotta blow your mind though thank
God for the white women
yo first of all Uncle Ruckus is one of
the best TV characters ever hey who do
you think would win in the fight
Charleston white Uncle Ruckus Uncle
Ruckus yeah somebody's [__] okay bro
Uncle Ruckus was [__] fighting with
Huey and you know Huey [__] he knew
like what was it like [__] some crazy
[__] Stinkmeaner too Stinkmeaner died
what the hell beat Satan up with that
fighting [__] and came back so hold on
listen
hey America this is Uncle Buck and even
though he dressed and sound like a
donkey you are listening to the greatest
white man oh Lord he smell like
furniture polish and lemon zest God
bless his white skin
I got a [__] Uncle Ruckus drop that's
[__] hard dog
that's odd do you remember uh you
remember Clayton Bixby of course Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle's that guy if
you want to see my face and then
everyone and then the guy's head
explodes
and then he divorced his own wife
because she was an n-word lover yeah oh
my God such a great we want to see her
face Clayton Bixby come on Clayton show
us your face yeah
hey shout out Dave Chappelle man he was
over there [__] with my dog Ralph
Barbosa that [__] was cool to see you
got uh Ralph Barbosa doing the skits
with you on your album yeah so we
actually have some uh some like you know
some anime to it too ah animation is
that started to roll out
uh I don't know but I know where it's
coming I don't you know yeah it's
definitely gonna be a part of the
project I just don't know
I don't think we have a drop date for it
maybe yeah so your album has like a a
very continuous theme throughout it
which is dope because I feel like a lot
of artists these days don't use skits
like when I was growing up skits were
like important parts of albums yeah
Eminem did them all Eminem Kanye like
[__] big pun like skits were the [__]
so you like like for you is it like
important to make sure you kind of you
know had a full theme throughout the
project I actually wasn't even I
wouldn't even thinking those kids I was
so worried about just making good music
My Boy Johnny was the one that was like
cause like me I'm not the type of person
where like I know albums and right and
songs and [__] like I'm a type person
like if it's here and I hear it and I
know it I know it I don't know the name
of it right you know what I'm saying so
that's how I am so like I wasn't even
thinking of that because I didn't know
that that was I didn't understand that
that was laid out in projects you know
what I'm saying so when he told me like
yeah you know the man all the all these
projects I have it you know it just made
sense I was like damn I want to do that
and then uh you know as soon as Ralph
got that he had a [__] notepad full
of you know all these notes and you know
we just went crazy from there
uh you have a song on your album is it
called briannon Brienne Brianna Brianna
it's kind of like uh your version of
like Eminem's cam a little bit you think
so how how much of a true story is well
we both got like women issues yeah I was
going to say like uh that's a pretty
crazy record yeah you've heard it yeah I
listened to the whole album oh Pride
that's all right that's hard as [__]
yeah yeah I got I got all the way to
like the last two records I didn't hear
I didn't hear the uh I think was it
Cowboy murder or some [__] or Cowboy
killer cowboy in New York oh Cowboy
killer yeah I didn't get to that the
last two from there yeah that's okay I
think the last record I heard was the
cowboy in New York record yeah cowboy in
New York was definitely fun I uh that
one was crazy to do well listening to
the album you obviously have a very uh a
very strong relationship with psilocybin
and mushrooms and other other substances
of course but uh yeah I got acid right
there the compound formula I got [__]
tap ass right here was going out his
head SpongeBob and Squidward it says
smoking seaweed I love drink
marijuana The Ugly Duckling what's
what's the worst trip you've ever had on
either shrooms acid or I don't know if
you've ever done DMT or anything like
real [__] yeah yeah yeah I did but
you did DMT I've done Molly I don't know
if there's the same right yeah yeah I
mean Molly I mean yeah Molly
um
I never had a bad trip on Molly that was
pretty cool I kind of just sunk into my
couch on that [__] you know what I'm
saying like acid acid was the ones where
I had bad trips what were you seeing
[__] I saw I saw sound travel
I couldn't hear and I saw sound travel
so you can hear the sound but you can
see it yeah couldn't hear it though what
the [__] yeah it was going out like
muffled like at first it sounded like I
was in water and people were talking and
screaming and then eventually it just
started going on
and then and then like I wasn't here but
I would I would feel the bass like and
then I would see it like
like uh so it was like imagine base
hitting and then it'll go like
like it would start fasting and you know
the PS you know the PS3 like when you
started it you know that [__] that's
what the sound looked like yeah it
looked like that the little intro screen
yeah it looked like that and but it was
only like in flashes of the bass
interesting yeah it was insane I was
butt ass naked running up and down
Sinclair Street in West Columbia I was
so [__] off my boy Billy was trying to
get me in the car and the window was
wrote down he was talking to me I was so
[__] off I couldn't even comprehend
how to get in the car trying to put my
leg through the window that was off of
acid off of acid I didn't get this I
didn't get acid because it's [__]
cool I got it to remember dude drugs are
real yeah like drugs are real like don't
[__] with even marijuana like you
shouldn't be playing with that I don't
think you should eat marijuana it can go
left if you eat it like Edibles yeah I
never had no edible that just smacked me
like that oh man
[__] that tell me tell me dog the worst
like the worst trip of my life wasn't
even on because I eat a lot of shrooms
but the worst trip of my life was
because I ate like 100 milligram edible
on accident
and I was I went to a risk I went to a
Ritz what the [__] is that what do you
mean on accident somebody gave me a cake
pop and I was only supposed to eat like
it was like a big cake pop and I was
always supposed to see like oh and I
didn't tell you so I had the whole thing
oh [__] and then I went to a yellow wolf
Ritz concert yellow wolf shout out
yellow wolf and uh dog
I was at the show and my my legs were
like implanted into the concrete
there was a [__] a cartoon Garfield
on stage yeah and his eyes were like
rolling like Garfield the cat they were
rolling like a slot machine
and
I could hear everyone's conversation
holy [__] so I could like hone in it was
like legit superpowers yeah like in the
middle of a concert I can hone in on
somebody like 100 yards away and listen
to their whole [__] conversation like
it was crazy that's insane and then I
puked everywhere
and then just the [__] every time I get
super [__] up the [__] that would
happen to somebody to freak out you when
you're [__] up what happened yeah so
like this [__] crazy Native American
dude got all [__] turned up and
started yelling about white people
stealing the country and [__] he got
into a fight with security like two feet
from me and I was just like dog is this
[__] real bro I'd have been out of there
when I started throwing up like I never
thought I think the only drug I've
thrown up I threw up on uh yellow's tour
bus so shut up
shrooms shrooms no no weed eating weed
oh [__] yeah no I've never had so
shrooms I'm like you know I love shrooms
yeah you've never had like a therapeutic
experience off of the shroomies we
haven't eaten enough man uh yeah I've
just tripped dick what'd you say I just
trip dig trip to Dick yeah like you know
how people like down tripping balls bro
you tripped dick yeah I was just like I
was right there with just like a little
level above you've never done DMT I
don't think uh I've done DMC like the
the low pen thing yeah that's [__]
is it yeah okay you got a free Basin
like a crack put me on babe if you get
DMT the real [__] you got a free Basin
like it's literally like smoking crack
Jesus Christ it's like you get the
[__] tinfoil and then you get the
pipe it's it's literally crack you've
done it no my best friend has I've done
the pen thing I'm scared dude what the
hell no I've seen I was with my best
friend when he did it no and I I bitched
out I ain't gonna lie to you like [__]
that out I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
when I'm ready you're done whippets no
yeah me neither like my homeboy he was
like dogs like the [__] craziest 15
seconds ever I'm like what 15 seconds
[__] yeah when I interviewed Ghana he
was whippeted out are you [__] me he
walked into the studio with like a
little [__] like box of [__]
and he was just lighting up the whippets
right before he went on camera yeah
Draco loves the whippets too I had a
whippo whip it infused Draco the ruler
interview oh that's hard by the time he
stood up it was just canisters like all
around me bro
rest in peace yeah the whippets are
serious but you have a [__] brain
aneurysm and die off you like uh you
like yeah I've never done cocaine one
time I remember I I was going to say
this earlier because it reminded me
think of it when you were talking about
throwing up on the drugs I think it's
the only drug I've ever thrown up on and
I don't drink like that right so
um and we were fishing and we had just
got back from fishing and we were
walking from the pond to my grandpa
house cocaine and fish yeah best ever
love it and uh and uh I'm on the way
back and do this like 8 P.M right and I
uh hit a [__] mean ass line dog I
mean that's fine and I'm like oh
I was like
nah I pushed that hoe back down and as
soon as we get to my grandpa's I had to
see him on the porch he's like what's up
you know he said something I just
[__] let it all out boom pooped I
puked all over the trailer
this was in a trailer yeah at my
grandpa's double what uh no I don't
think he's a double bed
I've lived in a trailer before yeah yeah
I know Robert trailers [__] shout out to
the trailers baby yeah shout out to the
trailers for real some of them trailers
is nice bro respect them double wides
too you wouldn't even know it bro on a
cool dog I'm cool with that like I'm
happy if God give me that I'm happy dog
like I just need like two acres in a
[__] double double fight with a
firehouse no [__] satellite on top
yeah I don't need no crazy [__] I don't
need no pool I don't need no none of
that you have an inflatable pool yeah
that's even better I do that with a
trampoline you know what I'm saying and
I'm cool with that you get on a
trampoline hell yeah yo this tooth is
fake because when I was a kid I said
some bitch's house when I was 14. yeah
and we're all jumping on the trampoline
at the same time and I flew so [__]
high in the sky dude I [__] ate [__]
on the concrete [__] my tooth it looked
like [__]
like a shittier white version of Nas as
a child
hey shout out my boy Caleb man I need
three more one time it was me him my dog
Pat and Eduardo and I'm talking to my
dog Caleb and he's like talking to make
conversation just stops and just
and just Falls forward right boom and
like I don't know why I should have
caught them but like I think wait what
this is on a trampoline on ground no on
on dab actually yeah oh yeah dab will
[__] you up so listen dog he just Falls
forward and like I kind of felt like a
hoe cause like I should have caught him
but I thought he was being funny so I'm
like he busted his tooth straightforward
face first on a metal bucket dog I look
at the bucket and the bucket looked like
it won but it was still you know what
I'm saying like in like it was beat in
and and then like bro he's face first
like like face down on the ground like
on his belly hands back like this and we
flip him over and we're like dog Caleb
are you good are you okay are you okay
dog what the [__] he was like yeah I'm
okay what are you talking about you
should see yourself yeah dog he didn't
even realize bro like he just laid there
and then he goes
I think my [__] my tooth is gone yeah
and like he's so non-slawn about
everything dog and I'm sitting here
looking for his tooth look in the bucket
the tooth is in the bucket I'm like
Jesus yeah so he's got a tube like that
too and he's like a sick ass night dog
it was scary honestly like in the moment
it was like what the [__] you know I'm
saying everyone's High your boy's
bleeding bro his flat yeah I fell face
first you say uh you had a a puking
experience on cocaine is it true if you
try to have sex on cocaine that your
your your Johnson will not be up to par
yeah like dope dick
that's a thing yeah I don't know I ain't
never I don't think I've ever
I don't think I've ever tried to [__] on
cocaine because every time I was on
cocaine I was doing some bad [__] right
or just not with women like I'll just
not I might have been with him just not
worried we've never liked because I'll
be so hype off this I've never done Coke
off a chick's ass
I feel like that see I've never done
cocaine but I had a girl sniff cocaine
off my lie bro that [__] sound cool
right but
that whole ass probably just you know
what I'm saying like well there's like
uh the opening scene of snowfall season
one episode one I saw it off uh wolf on
Wall Street well the the dudes oh in the
house coking this bitch's ass
I never seen it I put x on a [__] ass
though I put X on [__] ass hoe you put
ecstasy in the bitch's ass
yeah did you [__] the pill into her butt
no hell no I'm not an animal
could you imagine if you [__] her
after and then you're getting like
ecstasy like residue up your tickle
Jesus Christ
white powdered [__] that might be kind
of wild yeah that's some wild [__] yeah
you're nasty yeah
stuffing pills up bitch's asses I didn't
say [__] it though I mean
like maybe Lee you could leave the
finger in there yeah you gotta make sure
it gets in there definitely without a
doubt make sure to get in there how was
the uh session after that bro like she
got something to prove hmm
sucking dick look like she sneezed on it
yeah
if it doesn't look like you sneezed on
it I don't want it I don't want it I do
not want it I heard this girl say this
[__] oh there's this video of this girl
on Instagram right and you just see this
dude's legs in the air and it's his feet
right and then she come and you hear
dicks up and then she comes on she's
like everyone is talking dick like that
I don't hear y'all you ain't sucking
dick you ain't sucking dicks his ass too
bro she was doing she was eating ass she
was going crazy she was get yeah she was
if his legs were up in the air then you
see homeboys legs in the air and he's
like ah
there was a lot more going on than dick
sucking right there dog and [__] you not
that's on Instagram bro that was on
Instagram yo I just I just want oh I
didn't you know who Andrew Schultz is
the comedian no sir okay he had a Ralph
was on his show so he's got a podcast
called flagrant okay and they've played
this YouTube video it's on YouTube right
now okay it somehow has not been
violated or yanked down there's this gay
dude who's got a YouTube Channel and he
shaves his whole [__] on YouTube
and it's still on it's got 35 million
views and it hasn't been yanked it
hasn't been taken down this [__] is
insane because it's instructional so
y'all gone
that guy probably with me saying
specific words
you can't have a [__] twerking in your
video but this guy's whole [__]
busted open on YouTube oh I can't have
chickens fight but they got I like it so
have some [__] hairy ass booty hoe
bro it's [__] crazy though it's got
30 some odd million views what does it
look like
I was watching it on the podcast it was
blurred out don't lie I didn't look oh
lie I mean we could watch it now what it
look like
if he would if he's right-handed and he
was shaving with the left hand that's
kind of talent that's probably I that's
the only reason why I see why it's on
like valid on keeping it up
yeah bro think of it dog that's like
that's like writing with your left hand
and you're right-handed your [__]
except you're shaving your [__] well
you got to see this [__] it's it's
edited because I'm not gonna I don't
want to find the real one right of
course that'd be weird why would you
wanna yeah I wouldn't want to see that
where the [__] is this
you don't
Jesus
I don't even know where it's at whatever
there's a dude's [__] on YouTube
right now somewhere though sober I'm
sure if you want to find it you'll
[__] find it you sick [__]
Jesus hey how to save your [__] 101
when did you start doing the thing you
do with your tongue when you be
pronouncing that
my engineer says it sounds like you're
drumming when you rap yeah
uh maybe like my teenage
I don't want to say my whole life but so
is it ours only like like you can
somehow roll your tongue no matter what
you're saying it's like man it's bro
it's really just talking lazy just and
then like I don't fully pronunciate my
words and then the more aggressive I get
it just come out
yeah I think that's the best way I can
explain it
do it right now yeah
yeah like have you ever like just been
talking to a [__] and be like hell yeah
let me get rid of your [__] yeah it
come out all the time that shit's fire
it's they come out they like that [__]
they say freaky [__] about that I mean I
think it's funny you know what I'm
saying I think it's stupid but of course
they like it so who gives a [__] uh
Texas is on fire right now dude yes
Texas has always been on fire bro like
every favorite rapper of y'all is
y'all's favorite rapper my two favorite
rappers right now are you and big X the
plug and he's on on your album yeah but
both of y'all [__] that song
can wrap your ass off who's the other
guy on that song big yabo oh yeah who's
on tour with big X yeah so I think they
did that and I think that's what
introduced them to like getting it in
and uh I think uh
me and X had that song before both of us
blew up wow yeah and then we I just held
it for so long and then ended up [__]
with my boy Johnny and he got cuz over
there at the smoker Club so it was easy
to punch that in how did uh you end up
linking with uh Johnny shipes
uh my all right so look I started
[__] with my doggy Greg and then from
there you know what I'm saying we were
just doing [__] uh booking shows like at
the Lux and things like that taking it
one step at a time he ended up knowing a
dog named fee and uh you know that I
guess they were boys you know and fee
was the one that kind of connected the
dots for all of us nice yeah nice yeah
it's crazy too because like if you think
about like I feel like finally because
when I like when I was growing up
because I'm from Arizona right so like
we got I got a family in Queens Queens
Creek Queens Creek Phoenix yeah Queen
Creek yeah Queen Creek or Queens queen
Queen Creek Queen Creek it's a
neighborhood right it's a it's a city
like 45 minutes outside of Phoenix yeah
that's right it's like a suburb where
people like went out and built houses
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I had some
Kinfolk out there we have like growing
up like the low rider shows was like I
mean obviously MC Magic's from Phoenix
did you guys [__] with MC Magic in
Tucson or in Texas
yeah we uh we got the uh we we yeah yeah
uh but it was like magic it was little
Rob it was like bash who's
Vallejo Texas representative pretty girl
oh yeah that was right yeah for sure
super no it's not auto-tune it's a talk
box he's got the it's the top box he got
the hose in his mouth
the Roger the Troutman are you [__]
me I'm not [__] you sir
that's crazy
it does and Roger Troutman bro
this Fool's got [__] uh it's a talk
box bro
look this [__] is wait this is an
interview you don't want to see this
dog is that your boys
you're trying to clear a record pretty
girls we got we sampled that pretty I
gotta hear that yeah it's stupid hold on
you guys
where the [__] is his
here it is
yeah damn that's crazy man you should
hear that every morning see him freaking
the Box
so he'll be on stage with the [__]
body he's in that hoe
oh yeah that's a hard time
like a queen
that's hard
and he playing Keys bro
yeah no that's hard yeah
yeah no you guys gotta [__] with magic
wait pretty girls wait we sample that
pretty girls it's pretty gross NB Riders
MC Magic
Envy Riders
every Rider
are you sure because that's his group
because if it's an Emmy writer song
you're gonna have to clear it through uh
upstairs
magic if it's a magic record then oh
yeah no that's wait pretty girl oh no
attempty Riders you're gonna have to
clear that [__] through upstairs records
and they will hit you what was the name
of that lady is it Joe Lopez the lady
who ran uh you wouldn't know
yeah upstairs records actually I believe
based in Houston so you guys uh the lady
who will be clearing that for you will
probably [__] I'm in the penthouse
look that is a great rule of thumb if
you're an independent artist drop it
until they tell you to take it down yeah
yeah
they might they might they might
pause pause
give me that ass little boy
is this like a [__] uh like a
ulterior uh ego of yours where you turn
into like redneck OT I don't know dog
like I think I just I don't know get
over here God damn it
gotta stop the interview to say about
our good Folks at Odd Socks baby yeah
shout out to odd talks now this is what
I love about Odd Socks one their family
we love them but also they have the most
comfortable socks in the [__] world
all right now look they got the craziest
licenses you see the Jolly Rancher these
are actually flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the Odd Socks Basics now
these are just the basic socks so these
are in my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd Sox basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps uh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview I
don't know man I'm just [__] weird yo
have you ever been to Beaumont Texas uh
I've been around it yeah I've been there
I have a cousin that lives there and he
says it's like this redneck [__] yeah
yeah but it's a little bit of everything
you know Texas is
yeah there you go
West Columbia is a b count Brazoria
County we're in the area where we at so
that's the area you're from I'm from Bay
City that's like a county over okay is
that when you say I'm from Dirty Bay
Dirty Bay okay because Bay City Dirty
Bay be careful or the bay
um I like that dirty Bay so if you ever
hear me say be careful Texas that's
basically Texas
BYOB strip clubs in Dirty Bay
um we ain't gotta shoot clubs but in
Texas I feel like they're all bring your
own bottle yeah
I went to a strip club out there one
time and they were like we just sell the
ice bruh we just got ice bro that's
crazy yeah there's some byobs in Austin
for sure I went to a I went to but I
don't go to I went to the Yellow Rose in
Austin yeah right yeah it was cool my
dad my dad he punched in with all them
boys but yeah I uh I want a really go to
strip clubs no my dad had me at those
[__] when I was like 13. really
yeah I mean I was at a strip club I was
like 14 seeing a black girl this [__]
was crazy so listen you know how you
know how like we could Flex our picks
some of us can right yeah some of us
right right I've seen those black [__]
do that [__] her titties damn they
uppercut at her in the chin I was like
dog that's insane and they went this way
like she could do it by like yeah yeah
were they fake nah [__] no I don't think
so I don't know I was a kid I don't know
something like that I wouldn't I would
never be inside but I'd always be around
it you know I'm saying outside women
walking in and out to the car with my
dad you understand because my dad has
what they're doing you know just doing
what Chuck do was he pimping no I don't
know was he pandering
did he manage any Talent
it's something man something like that
yeah
yeah he was he was out there he just had
what they wanted you know and he didn't
call you need the outcall your dad's got
it right yeah it's a little extra right
he a cool ass [__] too as it is
you know what I'm saying
shout out to your dad yeah definitely
he's not even a rapper and he get red
carpet everywhere before because he's
that guy yeah you know the gfo provider
GFE provider there you go there you go
so if I want to if if my producer over
here who's single apparently right Cyrus
is single despite sleeping with the same
girl for a year Jesus Christ so if Cyrus
went to Texas and wanted to get laid
it's not a relationship that's just
that's just your dad could situate him
in Texas without a doubt okay
that's good to know without a doubt the
first I went to a circle when I was 14
it was in Mexico and I got my dick
sucked for 15. Jesus Christ yeah
Puerto Penasco
how long did you how long was it that
you remember
yeah I actually remember pretty vividly
so like of course yeah but like what is
it long like was it longer than being
high
no then I don't know if it was that much
because I would much rather got some
more what happened was
I my cousin paid to get me another get
me in yeah and then he went to the back
with a chick and then his chick I'm my
[__] child at the time but she takes
me to the back
and she starts I didn't have any money
right so she starts sucking my dick or
no she gave me a dance he paid for me to
get a dance that's it yeah so then she
took my dick out and she stopped right
before she's gonna put it in and then
she was like
and I was like how much you know and she
like put her head out the [__]
curtain to see if like the whoever
whoever was pimping us right was like
she said 15. uh she wanted you I said I
said my cousin my cousin will pay right
so this was crazy the whole time she's
sucking my dick she's paranoid yeah yeah
whoever's like Walking The Halls of the
[__] VIP area is gonna know she's in
your sucking dick so I bust and she
takes all my [__] and she just wipes it
on the wall animal
what the [__] and then we go sit down
like nothing happened and I just
remember thinking to myself like [__]
someone else is gonna go in there and
get my [__] on their shoulder dog listen
to this hold on I'm gonna cut the camera
one time I guess they're gonna see it
regardless long long ass time ago I was
knocking this hole down right and then
boom I'm talking about nut it all in her
[__] bro oh like a Twinkie right and
check this out she told me she was like
sorry Daddy I didn't know I just popped
a perk I was like [__] I don't give a
[__] why are you telling me that you're
telling me I don't care yeah I did I'm
all right nah but then it was like a
huge like I couldn't offer like after
that I don't think I've ever really just
chopped it up with it like that again
like that was a that's when I realized
yeah I don't like girls either they do
drugs no you don't eat well no because
like I like you know it's kind of my boy
G said this check this out so I was I
had this home girl with me
keep in mind this [__] told me
she told me some [__] look this
Anonymous friend of yours told you some
[__] you're right I can't I don't know I
don't know how to speak on it so [__]
great I mean [__] my boy G saw a
homegirl do this to me from across the
room she said hey I looked up and she
went
[Laughter]
oh that looks like come eat my [__] nah
okay okay I like gangster ass [__] like
five something up all right fire
something up and that's when he said bro
like I'll give a [__] I'll give a [__]
some weed I'll give it you know what I'm
saying but as soon as she start asking
for it it's a problem ew I'll offer it
can't do it you know what I'm saying
that so that's when they kind of made it
click for me like man you know what he
right and then like a week later
homegirl like yeah pop the perk poppy
sorry I'm like oh [__] I didn't even
notice you shouldn't have said nothing
yeah yeah
also like who cares you came in her
butthole right without a doubt yeah was
it messy like have you ever had anal sex
and had the [__] on the dick ever never
shout out to you that in a thousand out
here with the ain't no luck yeah but I
also don't just be sticking to
everything you shouldn't be yeah Houston
got a is it at a hard time at an
all-time high right now with syphilis I
just saw that article you saw that
sifis have you ever had STD
uh uh I had a gonorrhea are you [__]
me yeah it sucked that's wild are you
[__] me right now all right
gonorrhea like I don't know 10 years ago
maybe yeah your B's getting through that
I mean it was a shot of pedestal under
the ass really that was it really yeah I
thought that was [__] was like uncurable
no you're thinking of the herpes herpes
is uncurable oh okay I think I think I
had chlamydia as a kid yeah chlamydia
gonorrhea and syphilis is shot of
penicillin up the ass that's what's up
no I think I took like a pill or yeah
where it's like a giant pill yeah and
then they're like fat ass horse pill and
they're like don't [__] for two days
sorry can't do it that [__] hurts when
you piss for sure I know I don't think I
burned oh I did I ain't gonna read oh
yeah
that [__] was terrible oh bro hold on
explain that to me
so I was so you didn't know until you
pissed you had it or you knew and then
you were like [__] I gotta piss well so
what happened was at the time
I [__] this stripper Jesus Christ son
and at the time I was in a relationship
and so
I woke up in the middle of the night and
my dick was stuck to my boxers
[Laughter]
so I was like that boy had cookie crumbs
on the tip of his dick right imagine
having to wake up and you gotta and
they're like no no it was just like it
was like my dick was Dripping right
that's why it is yeah and then I pissed
and it burned like a [__] and I
was like all right let me cause a fight
with my uh at the time significant other
and uh you know just kept fighting for
about a week and so I went to the left
the spot the next day and got the the
old shot up the ass so you told her you
had it [__] no no who told who your
significant other of course not I
cheated on her but that's why I'm like
so wait hold on so wait she never knew
what do you mean saw the argument I just
started fighting with her so we didn't
she didn't try to [__] oh okay it makes
yeah okay my fault I got lost yeah
so you start the fight and you're like
all right cool I can't have sex for like
four or five more days because I got the
rear of the Gunner
that blows dick was it worth it
yeah
it was worth it
yeah it was going down like James
bonding this [__] God damn I
respect it dog yeah it was like you know
what a little [__] trip to the lab
you get the shot up the ass 72 hours
later you're cleared up how many how
many how many diseases do you think is
acceptable and so like you're like oh
you're a dirty ass [__]
five five yeah I'll take that especially
if you're from where you're from if
everyone's got chlamydia [__] yeah dogs
it's crazy Jesus even even AIDS like Bay
City got AIDS out the ass dog literally
it's literally out of the ass that's
where they come from literally like dog
like it's it's there
um where do you find women when you're
like in dating mode is it the DMS is it
nah I don't really I don't really just
be on the phone like that like like I
got you got to be here like I gotta you
got to know like you gotta meet up have
an interaction with somebody yeah like I
gotta like the majority of the time and
just be like off some like like if I'm
girls right here [__]
I like it yeah
um how I'm not gonna go out the way
they're like hey [__] what's up what
you doing or like meet her like hit her
with the heart eyes and the DMS yeah no
no and I've heard from a lot of girls
that they don't even like that [__] so
like it make me not insecure but like it
made me not even want to text them like
because I think I overthink it like I'm
gonna hit them they're gonna be like oh
this thirsty ass rapper right and I'm a
rapper so like they expect that [__] and
it's like I'm I'm not you know what I'm
saying I'm not really no dirty ass [__]
like that I don't need I don't be
[__] like that you know what I'm
saying so like
I just avoid it anyways so like I just
that's what I'm saying I just I just
catch them in person
um how important it is is it for you to
kind of like make sure because I feel
like
you know we're having like a Renaissance
of like Mexican artists that are just
just flat out like dope as opposed to
like what I feel like when I was growing
up you'd be like oh yeah that's a
Chicano rapper like they're not really
making music that like the world can
enjoy they're making a very specific
type of music to a specific audience and
if something crosses over cool for you
you're just like [__] amazing bro
like because but you also represent who
you are I mean it's in your name right
right exactly but I I also um like I
wasn't boxed in when it came to music
you know what I'm saying my dad and my
mama was jamming everything from here to
here you know what I'm saying so uh I
think I I just I think the only reason
why that is just because I just grew up
in a different area you know I'm saying
sometimes that's all they know yeah and
that's why I come out like that
who was like uh was there anybody from
[__] Texas that was popping as a
Mexican back in the day ESPN little Bing
Big flake SPM is the guy Lil Bing
shout out to uh dope House Records you
know Lil Bing I don't know low Bean
little Bing low Bing I do not sir and
big flake they got that house party that
house party I drank Bacardi uh with my
Rolexes yeah well my legs it's a car key
yeah there we go there you go hey y'all
really be like is SPM like [__] like
a like a god figure in Texas just to a
live majority of them yeah what about to
you no not really yeah because he's kind
of a controversial guy because he's
obviously in prison for some crazy [__]
yeah but I don't even think of that [__]
like I uh cause like I like I said I
already wasn't really just glorifying
him like that so like I already don't
even put my mind into that right like I
mean he [__] with me and I respect that
so I [__] with him back that's as far as
it goes have you linked up with Baby
Bash yet who's he lives out there no not
really you guys should smoke together
and share stories about stuff and
ecstasy in women's [__] I believe it
he seems like he has [__] up every
porn star you could think of I believe
it he was a pretty ass [__] in
the day yeah bash was smashing for sure
for sure hey who's your goats like give
me your top five all time man your
favorite not like who you know just give
me your favorite I like I'm gonna put
like my Rushmore your Mount Rushmore I
think I've done this twice a day
and I'm Gonna Keep it the same I got
I put big l50 Wayne and Hobson wow
Hopson big big L 50 Wayne and Hobson
what was the because I remember when I
first downloaded the seven minute
freestyle with Big L and Jay-Z that 98
the 98 yeah
and from there I was like hooked to
biggest
I'm so ahead of my time my parents ain't
met yet yeah yeah
yeah that is and he like murdered uh he
[__] murdered Jay-Z yeah I was gonna
say if he was still alive do you think
we'd have a Jay-Z
well from what I heard before he passed
he was supposed to be signing with
Rockefeller
so I think they would have been heavily
connected of course but like
yeah yeah Jay-Z was doing his thing
because you got to think lifestyles of
the poor and dangerous came out and was
kind of like not necessarily I got that
CD in the truck right now great [__]
album yeah great you know what I liked
about him put it on yeah I'll put it on
it's great but you ever hear the song
devil's son yes oh my God so that's
that's the one where he's like this like
with the glasses right what project is
it oh you're thinking of the big picture
no devil's son was just like a Lucy it
wasn't on either one of his albums so
he's talking about being the devil's son
yeah yeah no he crashed you know Big
Al's one of them once so what so Hopson
is kind of interesting because he
doesn't get enough love I feel like you
know bro that [__] I don't know
he was [__] on a lot he would talk
so much [__] but it's because he had a
chip on his shoulder you know I
understand it [__] I used to be mad at a
lot of [__] hey you know my
friends like some of my I used to have I
used to be because I'm an angry ass
little [__] right you know what I'm
saying and I hate that [__] dog like my
anger honestly like it like I'll be I
used to get so angry dog that whenever I
calmed down I feel like I got jumped
because like I'd be so like you know
what I'm saying like you feel like you
have anger issues man [__] yes dog I've
been [__] my whole life you know what
I'm saying anyways uh
uh [__] I'm a Hobson yeah yeah anyways
Hopson you know I understand oh yeah my
fan I understand why he feel that way
you know he just he just angry little
[__] you know but I remember my
friends like I would get new fans and I
would be kind of not mad but I'd be like
[__] you should have been on this jump
right you know what I'm saying but then
I realized like man he probably just
ain't he you know I'm saying Word of
Mouth ain't got to him yet that's all it
is is it hard for you because like
you're I mean [__] you got a song rap
caviar right now uh this Johnny Dang
record is going [__] nuts for you
yeah is it hard for you because you've
kind of had like a little like cult
following for a minute right so now that
you are like popping for real and like
going viral yeah is it kind of hard or
weird at least for you to just get just
random like kind of passive fans that
like aren't I mean it's good for your
pockets I'm sure oh yeah without a doubt
but like you know what I'm saying like I
I expected it I knew they was going to
[__] with me you know what I'm saying
and I'm of course I'm grateful for him
and I understand the power that I have
with them and I like that [__]
but uh
man I've been rappers I was four years
old I've always looked at myself like a
rapper and you're like your top four was
very rapidly for sure
duh I like it man yeah yeah baby yeah
thank you what's your very much for your
Mount Rushmore ah it's nice oh that's
crazy I've been jamming the [__] out of
heaven shout out to NAS Heaven's a great
record yeah
um yeah he's crazy it's probably J
c yeah Jay-Z now look a man okay
the other two I guess like if you were
just talking about my top four favorite
yeah
it's probably Jay
Nas
Andre 3000 that's cool that's a cool one
and
Ghostface Killer Ghost Face Killer wow
that's a cool one
that's a cool one though I'm from
Arizona ocean
ass [__] bro people be reacting
to Johnny Dang thinking I'm Paul Wall
thinking Johnny Dang I mean Jake and
Paul Wall Johnny Dang thinking Jody's
Paul Wall you know saying they'll see
swangers and be like what the [__] is
that you know what I'm saying like bro
there's a lot of uncoached [__]
out here 100 I mean you guys do
everything different in Texas though
I'll say that you go to Texas it's just
a Vibe bro it's like man dog it goes
down yeah you guys the cars look
different
yeah I I think everybody got their own
Steelo though you know I think that's
cool as [__] though like you could see
somebody oh yeah he from Catlett or he
even hear the way they talk oh yeah he
definitely from New York there's a way
people from here talk hell yeah
give me like an impersonation what's up
fool okay
these are my Mexicans all of them even
even
uh what's up
man Slide the block catch the Ops you
need van cat you're not gonna catch me I
mean I'm in Texas talking about what's
up huh uh where the toilet bowl at I got
shot in Texas like hardcore like orderly
fools man in the valley yeah
or even like Lubbock yeah I think a lot
of the like like I think guys like
yourself pays a place you got a lot of
flavor coming out of Texas man hell yeah
but man we just
I don't know how to say it we're just
Southern yeah it's like The Best of Both
Worlds kind of you guys got great
Mexican food
not as great as here but great don't do
that dog so we'll have a whole argument
what are we talking about what are you
talking about LA Mexican food is
superior to Texas are you [__] me
son
it's not even close not again what do I
use for video what kind of media I use
y'all use goat yeah see nah that's where
you're [__] up we use fajita
see right
you know who but you know really has the
best Mexican food in San Diego
because it's just Tijuana it's like you
go to like Chula Vista San Diego got
that [__]
out here
okay yeah come on Texas got cool Mexican
food but it's like that's my dog ybe
right here
why be what's the what's the hood name
I'm from West Covina City West Covina
shout out is that the 562 626. look at
me [__] up my shout out shout out I
think every time I go through West
Covina I get Raising Canes oh yeah
hey post Malone got that pink one
a pink Raising Cane in Utah
that's [__] ridiculous I want to go I
love Utah we went to Salt Lake City
downtown Salt Lake City the Mormons is
out bruh bro yeah it's cool though
Hey whenever I heard I was going to Salt
Lake City I started looking up videos of
Mormons in them dog these [__]
moved a house like they they like they
had the floor out you know what I'm
saying and they they were all standing
up like with the [__] the bass you
know what I'm saying holding that [__]
and they were in in like bro like it was
like they were all in sync and the way
they [__] maneuver together and work
together is like Mormons are great
people so I went to high school in a
Mormon like they like they're gonna
survive well they also you know they
don't [__] they dock
they can't thrust they put the dick in
and has to sit there until the guy comes
you [__] me no yeah soaking
nah yeah
hold on wait a minute they can't thrust
it's against their religion to thrust
soaking in that [__]
so if you're like a Mormon woman low-key
your kegel game gotta be crazy
holy [__] that's I want bro I want to
knock one of those man Bama pajamas down
uh God damn aren't you yeah
that's crazy if that was the case if I I
would just like I would just like
squeeze as far as I can in there and
like and just sit there you know what
I'm saying like a full-on I think that's
what they do that's because they have to
they can't waste uh a seed yeah so like
every nut has to be for a child that's
why if you notice a lot of more dude I
ain't gonna lie 12 people hey I'm gonna
knock them plenty of my kids uh the
[__] down the drain yeah
out one time
you ever have to pay for an abortion no
sir good for you no sir yeah that's a
rough thing yeah I was almost giving up
for abortion my nanny was like what the
[__] no wait what yeah my mom my mama's
gonna get me up but because her mom was
like what are you doing like how old was
your mom when she had you you don't make
me asking younger I don't know she was
26 she was 26 when she passed and she
passed in 07 I was eight
hey hey
damn 19 it's all right that's crazy I
had my son when I was 17. that's cool
man I want kids I want more now like I
wish I started when I was 20. well you
know what I wish I was three kids deep
right now really [__] yes that's a wild
that's a very Mexican thing to wish
Jesus bro having kids just fight you got
kids having kids father who got config I
know that [__] man that's just fine
you're about to go on a tour and [__]
yes it's cool as [__] bro you got to get
all this rap star [__] out first like
you're you gotta get the rap rapper [__]
out of you like for real you got to go
through this without worrying about like
FaceTiming at the end of the night okay
check me out that's why I'm boom get her
pregnant right now that way the first
nine months first nine months in the
first like bro oh I don't got my and you
know what shout out my dog e because he
helped me you know what I'm saying he's
the one that broke it down to me like
this and he was like what you should do
because I was talking about I was like I
want kids you know all this and that and
I was like should I wait should I should
I what should I do right and he was like
this what I'll tell you he said
the first you know I'm saying he said
this is how he feel of course the first
nine months I ain't got to be there the
first two years of the baby being born I
got that's all Mama and grandma said
right I don't got to be talking to my
baby until my baby can fully comprehend
what the [__] I am telling you so just
gone for two years not gone of course
look of course not gone no but like but
like you can go and hit the road I could
go do what I got to do that way while
you handling all that I'm handling this
so we can chill right right right right
right you know what I'm saying of course
I'm gonna be in the kid's life I'm not
gonna miss the baby being born I'm not
gonna miss times where I'm talking to it
in the belly you know I'm gonna be here
for that [__] but baby I got [__] to do
hey let's stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our good Folks at King
Palm that's right man shout out to King
Palm uh we're talking about nothing but
that organic all right that natural
them leaves all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg Kev try either one of those I
forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong also want to shout out to our good
Folks at Blue chew baby shout out to
Bluetooth now this was going on with
Bluetooth man everybody keeps asking me
this Bluetooth work yes it works but
don't take my word for it you're gonna
get a month for free when you go to
bluetooth.com and you use the promo code
bootleg a month for free now what is
Bluetooth fellas if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction fellas if your dick
is not getting as hard as you'd like it
to maybe for your wife oh I don't know
listen all you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com it has the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but
it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discretely of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going in
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right blueshear.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're gonna give you a
month's supply for free just five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview have you ever been to the
Houston Rodeo no sir I'm not going to
town performing there but hang on you're
coming soon I don't know but I uh
so like I you know I'm saying I kind of
felt that I was like damn I should just
knock off the kitchen yeah knock all
this [__] out be chilling and by then
man I could you know really like [__]
with my kid like that because I
obviously in my dog you know what I'm
saying that he has his kids and bro that
[__] look fire I missed out on a
childhood you know what I'm saying and
I'm not the happiest person right now
I'm not depressed neither but I feel
like there's [__] missing in my life and
I feel like I'm gonna find my happiness
in my family do you have any uh do you
have a dog yeah Bushwick Bill oh that's
a sick neck what kind of dog is it he's
a he's a pocket but he's a runt so he
looked like a micro a little [__] like
a like a buoy yeah like Bushwick Bill oh
wow yeah do you feel like it's kind of
like it's like a kid you know that
definitely I tell all my homies the car
seat my truck stairs in my bed [__]
you know what I'm saying like this
[__] yeah me too yeah I have two dogs in
my bed every night me and my wife just
said yeah that's Pomeranian or Frenchie
that's what's up you ever wake up to a
[__] uh [__] a a duty on the
[__] bed I better not but I wake up
with his ass in my face all the time my
dog be rubbing his balls on me all the
time it's like in avoidable yeah I just
got Larry's balls on my arm every day
Harry's balls Living Like Larry yeah
Bushwick I ain't gonna lie bushwick's
balls like one sits on the other but I
think it's because he has no room he has
no legs he's tiny yeah so like they just
kind of like sit on each other uh you
saw me or Mount Rushmore what about your
favorite albums ever
um like I said you're not an album guy
you were saying yeah but if I you know
what [__] if there was that one album
I'd say the J Cole that uh the Forest
Hill Drive yeah Forest Hills Drive yeah
great album yeah and that's because like
I know the name of that I've heard
everyone that's one that I'm familiar
with even that wish I went with Kendrick
the Mad City good kid Mad City yeah that
was pretty dumb too for sure even yeah
oh [__] get rich the whole soundtrack
yeah
yeah every yeah all of that um
yeah the album not the there was two
there was a soundtrack which had like
yeah do you think of the album but even
the soundtrack was stupid it had that
with your head boy the MLP [__] yeah
yeah you like G Unit of 50. what does
that mean it's the same no one is a
group and one is just dolo are we saying
do I like
beg for mercy from G-Unit or like a solo
50 album yeah SOLO 50. yeah keep Richard
I train yeah but I love Lloyd Banks man
yeah Lloyd Banks different he's a
punchline King bro he was he I don't
call him p.o.k okay I probably gotta go
back and jam him again
for sure yeah he was like he was he
could rap He had ordered like bars at 50
for sure but he had the Melodies and
hooks and [__] yeah yeah yeah the player
said cuz has some punch lines uh who has
been somebody that's reached out to you
that kind of like you had to like pinch
yourself or be like what the [__] I got
a DM from this person this person knows
who I am because you've been getting a
lot of notoriety ladies Russ yeah he
just dm'd you no I uh I posted something
I posted uh I said as a rapper I follow
you know what I'm saying like this is
who I follow I was really just giving
games to like other rappers right like
who I watch and then I guess he saw me
posting you said Russ yeah yeah yeah and
then uh I added them and you know you
ended up responding you have to do a
record together eventually but I don't
ever want to be that type of
[__] that'll just be asking [__]
so like I kind of let it happen
um he does uh those Chomp CDs where he's
like gets all the lyrical [__]
on some joints he should get you on some
[__] hopefully man we're gonna see what
he's talking about any of the news what
the [__] are you waiting on doggy any of
the New York guys tapping like any of
the Griselda guys or no they don't like
me dude
I don't think that's true no I don't
know bro you know what I have noticed
some people be thinking I'm a [__]
man why I don't know because you wear a
cowboy hat and carry Chicken around on
[__] YouTube
like maybe [__] [__]
just think on my [__] and uh I guess
I can be but like I'm not and uh like
like CJ shout out CJ Casino I remember
one time I saw I watched this
[__] like watch me and I watch
some people you check me out all this
[__] and you know what it's at a hot
Park photo shoot and uh
and uh shout out Jacob and happy and uh
I was over there and Miss Megan came up
and she asked me something
and I was like oh yeah yes man I know
man whatever the [__] I said but I guess
man no man you know I'm a good
respectable kid I've always been that
way and uh I guess he saw that you know
he kind of just like I see him watching
me you know what I'm saying and then
when he sees like I'm not who he thought
I was he came and was like hey man I
[__] with you dog like you hard and
stuff and uh you know I was like [__]
yeah I appreciate you that's Travis
Scott tapped in uh-uh it's about it's
gonna happen you got to I don't know
what they following what the [__] they
waiting on that's what I'm saying like
I'll be getting I don't know because I
got an emotional come in emotional ass
[__] I don't know what the [__]
it is but like I'll be like
[__] and now it's now or never
yeah they're gonna tap in I mean you're
I mean you know hey when you have a
record that's like Johnny Dang it's a
hit record it's free promotion for
Johnny Dang is he just giving you grills
for Life him and Paul are they just like
whenever you need one pull up we got you
for every million streams we'll give you
another like ring or something no but I
didn't I don't expect nothing you know
I'm saying I didn't do it for that I did
it because like it was just a part I'm
not even talking about [__] jury it's
something about being high 100 you know
what I'm saying it's a little racist
yeah a little bit it's like 10 which I
think we're comfortable with yeah
definitely yeah so I mean [__] you know
and that's what I look like you know
what I'm saying so it's because it's
like uh
it could mean two things
job that's what people I think
you know more yeah that's how everybody
else is what's your uh what's your
favorite song on your album
all of them that's in it [__]
terrible answer you think so yes sorry
okay
why the name give me get break down the
name of the album in the con I mean
obviously we talked concept a little bit
we said Ralphie was doing skits but
what's the actual concept uh you know
I'm a test is missing you know what I'm
saying so like I feel like it's a big
difference between any other type of
Mexican and uh Lone Star you know being
Texas Lucha though I was always been
I've always been a fan of wrestling and
you know what I'm saying I feel like it
was a good representation of the Mexican
culture so like Lone Star Lucha Lord
just
it just sounds like a [__] sick
restaurant too yeah maybe one day it
just made perfect sense to me you know
what I'm saying and then after that it
eventually became an ego you ever
watched Nacho Libre yes do we think
natural like by the way it's a great
movie did you tell them that they were
the large chips it's so good
so good remember who he [__] jumped
on when he jumped on the Ignacio and he
[__] farted uh sound like a [__]
car game out I was like [__] your
[__] just it's crazy because if you
think about it like in 2023 like Jack
Black couldn't play that guy it'd be
racist
they'd be like yo this like you know it
was crazy and you know what's crazy I
thought he was missing my whole life
Jack Black because of that movie
so he's because he's a sick ass actor
bro he sold that [__] yeah bro okay how
would you all right so like I saw this
thing I mean what okay so hold on
it's racist for him playing on his skin
no I don't know I'm not saying it's
racist I'm saying that like in 2023 they
would be like
yeah it's [__] funny
oh [__]
yeah he yeah you're right you're right
you're right that's crazy I didn't even
think of that uh album comes out next
Friday
this is the next is it next Friday yes
next Friday
damn July 28th I'm so happy dog like I'm
just ready for the world to hear it it's
a dope album I think my favorite record
was was it called groovin groovin that
shit's hard that's like kind of your
like Ode to your uh your your substance
that's the OTV gorilla that's just crazy
you remember that Greg
that's the old TV gorilla man
come on man yeah I'm excited dog I just
you know I love this [__] man so it's
just easy to [__] do it and um I'm
grateful man I know this isn't your
first body of work but are you like
considering this because this is kind of
like your first project since you're
blown up it's just like I consider like
my first project yeah cause like
it's so it's so much more yeah it's so
much more than just you know songs to
put together is there's actual emotions
there's thought you know what I'm saying
there's like [__] meaning behind [__]
right
tattoo on my [__] belly you know what
I'm saying you got a lot of [__] sick
tits dude thanks shout out to Weezy this
one probably hurt the most my kneecap
that [__] yeah that's getting right up
into Texas Mexican is that the [__]
Texas Chainsaw man oh wow Jesus
they've remade that [__] way too many
times dog and they're all garbage yeah
it's like every time they reset it
honestly I don't even like scary movies
anymore because like they're just too
predictable like when I watch when I say
I want to watch scary [__] I want to
watch something that [__] disturbs me
to the core of who I am you ever watch
The Human Centipede yeah but that's not
that's not disturbing did you watch the
second one the prison
that one too that one was a little bit
more better yeah I'm saying damn shits
is crazy the prison hey who was homeboy
that passed uh he played in Roscoe
Jenkins he played in The Green Mile
uh Michael Clark Duncan yeah he was the
he started the human centipede in the in
the what the fourth one or the third one
how many are there they did a whole
prison bro I only saw one and two bro he
[__] this [__] while she was in a
coma Jesus Christ he said like he was
all like he was like I'll make you come
in a coma what is what's your favorite
TV shows Boondock anything on Adult Swim
just Adult Swim you like uh what was the
one with the cheeseburger and the shake
uh uh Hunger Force yeah hunger for us
yeah yeah french fries and sag the
meatball what about like you [__] with
South Park of course yeah what do you
think Boondocks is the best cartoon show
ever
foreign
opinion yeah and it's because the first
two seasons because season three was a
little shaky maybe that was the one
where the the original writers like
weren't writing on the show oh okay yeah
the first two seasons yeah definitely
and it just it just sucks that there's
not enough you know what I'm saying I go
live and live in color was another TV
show I [__] with I don't know if you
know that bro Tommy Lee Thomas
the Wayne Bros Jim Carrey [__] Jamie
Foxx was on that JLo everybody blew up
off that I feel like that [__] in Mad TV
yeah yeah [__] Saturday Night Live
uh uh Saturday night I wasn't really
into that one uh uh
Chris [__] Farley was dope on
Saturday Night Live what the [__] was it
you remember Mr MIDI Mr nah Mr Media was
on the door so that [__] was wild like I
remember being scared of the manager he
was like in a wheelchair and he was all
purple his eyes were poking out their
puppets and then it was a TV show Mr
Meaty Mr Meaty oh [__] yeah I think like
the first episode this [__] puts her
hand in a [__] frying pan in it
Friday
yeah well there you have it well listen
man the new album's coming uh who else
on the album you got obviously Paul Wall
John uh Johnny thing
all right Paul Wall Jordy uh big X big X
big yabo we got sploosh he did the 15.
oh you know what favorite song I ain't
gonna say it's my favorite but it's the
one I jammed the most okay which one
Fitzy Miss cause all right featuring my
boy sploosh sploosh that's a hell of a
name yeah he's from Houston
y'all got good names out there yeah
yeah he's all right he do his thing man
you know he's kind of on the come up I
just believe in him so hopefully he gets
his head out his ass and fix it well go
support the album when it drops uh
appreciate you coming through man it was
good to finally meet you brother dog it
was a pleasure thank you so much man
there it is that Mexican OT yeah yeah
boom hey this interview is brought to
you by our good Folks at hardean all
right shout out to the Jardin family in
Las Vegas makes you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection to previous premium cannabis
you can ask for plus when you go to
Hardy in Las vegas.com you can check out
all the other cool stuff they got going
on you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas hardine is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to Jardine and when you get
there you tell them wonderful Bud
tenders that I sent you and they're
gonna take care of you Harding
underscore Las Vegas go follow him and
uh yeah we got another interview coming
soon